hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
Gore's I prefer to think of it Dear John
and Hank the podcast where we answer
your questions provide a dubious advice
and give you all the week's news from
Mars and AFC Wimbledon but first John do
you have a poem for us I do have a poem
for you got out sighs thinking that
we're kind of like missing a segment
from the podcast where we just just
where I asked you how you're doing I
find out what's you know how how things
are so how are you oh well I was
expecting a poem and now I have a
question being thrown at me I'm great I
mean a poem will come in the fullness of
time I just I just wanted to know if
there's anything going on with you if
you're up to anything well see I want to
talk about myself but I know it's polite
to let you talk about yourself first
when this podcast comes out I will be in
France um and I will have been in France
for about a week and hopefully I'm
having a good time there on a little
mini vacation that started out with work
with the nice I stayed in France
well congratulations is the future you
on getting to visit France I was just in
France very recently as part of you know
I it occurs to me that lots of people
don't know that we are not just
professional podcasters with a podcast
sponsored by shirttail shirttails
the 1980s children's cartoon that
changed lives including ours no we are
not just professional podcasters we also
have other jobs Hank is an internet
entrepreneur vlog brother crash course
co-created lizzie bennet diaries which
won an Emmy
scishow lots of things what else do you
do Hank I can't remember VidCon dftba
records I make videos with you on this
channel called vlogbrothers crash course
I mentioned several of those things but
clearly you weren't listening to me um
yeah so mostly I am the tail to Hanks
comet but I also had this other job
which is that I write books or I guess
maybe I should say that I used to write
books since I haven't written one in
more than three years and one of the
books that I wrote Paper Towns is being
turned into a movie that comes out in a
few weeks and so I have been traveling
constantly so I actually spent 22 hours
in Paris Hank I left the hotel precisely
twice
umm-hmm mostly I was I was in Europe I
was in Europe for five days I spent
almost all of my time in hotel basements
which were which are lovely I mean some
of the loveliest hotel basements that
Europe has to offer doing press junket
stuff but I did leave the hotel twice in
Paris wants to visit the dentist because
no visit to Paris is complete without a
dental appointment and then once to do a
signing that was supposed to be at a
bookstore but turned out to be just sort
of in a large public square but from
what I could gather Paris is lovely it
has some of the very best hotel
basements that you can find in all of
Europe so enjoy your time in France
that's what I'm saying can I get can I
get to the poet poem part of the day
yeah you can tell us well now it sounds
it sounds really exciting and and I look
forward to your new blog hotel basement
reviews.com oh my god there's some great
ones
which reminds me by the way that dear
Hank and John is sponsored by Paper
Towns Paper Towns the new movie coming
out July 24th in the US and other times
elsewhere in the world this is a poem
that by Walt Whitman it's designed to
make Hank angry and it's called when I
heard the learn'd astronomer when I
heard the learn'd astronomer when the
proofs the figures were ranged in
columns before me when I was shown the
charts and diagrams to add divide and
measure them when I sitting heard the
astronomer where he lectured with much
applause in the lecture-room how soon
unaccountable I became tired and sick
till rising and gliding out I wandered
off by myself in the mystical moist
night-air
and from time to time looked up in
perfect silence at the Stars hey you
know that doesn't make me angry uh I
just think that what Whitman could enjoy
both of those things in in different
ways
those are both wonderful things I like
listening to learn it astronomers myself
and looking at the stars in the mystical
mists or whatever he said it was well I
think it's the I think it's the debate
between whether there's value to
mystical experiences and in
and whether science can damage that
value hi this is a phone where I
disagree with Walt Whitman he has a few
of those because I do believe that
science only improves our sort of like
mystical relationship with the Stars I
mean the more I know about the Stars the
more kind of beautiful and massive and
overwhelming they become and that's very
close to the feeling of the mysterium
tremendum you know that that fear and
awe and overwhelm overwhelmingness that
accompanies kind of experiences with
with the divine or with the radically
other or whatever but I still love the
poem it's funny thing about if anything
about poems Hank sometimes I disagree
with with the argument of a poem but I
find its language and but I find it's a
language and rhythm so compelling that I
can't I can't help but like it you know
yeah oh absolutely
except for the part except for the part
where I don't really get poetry because
it well like I actually I like it a lot
more when you're reading it to me I have
a hard time reading poetry because it
doesn't have the normal line breaks and
it's taken me long enough to be able to
read words the way that they're normally
presented that when they're presented
differently I have a very hard time with
reading comprehension and I just
completely lose track of what's going on
so I think that all poetry should be
read to me by someone but preferably
John Green if that's an option can we
get to the questions yes yes of course I
live asks Dear John and Hank are you
worried about the disappearance of the
bees and do you know of anything people
can do to help save the bees this is
obviously more of a Hank question than a
John question but I just want to jump in
real quickly here and say live as far as
I can tell from my backyard the bee
situation is I'm not concerned about the
bee situation in my backyard is this a
moment bank where maybe anecdote is not
singular of data and that sometimes just
because you see bees doesn't mean there
isn't a larger bee issue there's a
larger bee issue there is definitely a
larger bee issue that the bee issue that
we're having is mostly an economic sort
of commercial bee issue so there are
bees all across America
that are driven around to crops and they
are planted outside of the crops during
the pollination season and then and then
brought to new crops when it's time to
pollinate those crops and the bee
farmers who do this are paid to do it
and then they at the end of the year
also have honey that they can sell and
in it is a it is a job that people have
it's not so much a wild bee problem it
is it's more of a commercial bee problem
and it is a huge problem because
commercial bees in addition to providing
jobs for those lovely beekeepers and
honey for all of us also produce you
know all of the crops by pollinating
them and crops that don't get pollinated
do not turn into food and that's bad and
they do not turn into seed for next
year's harvest and that's bad as well
and colony collapse disorder is
basically a huge widespread unknown
phenomenon in which the bee hive just
suddenly dies and and that is happening
to a huge percentage of commercial
beehives and the reasons for this are
not well known though they are being
increasingly well studied and likely
have something to do with sort of a
combination cocktail of pesticides that
should not should not and are not being
sprayed on the crops that bees are
currently pollinating but may be being
sprayed on nearby crops or may just be
still on those crops after after a
longer than we thought they were
sticking around and the way that all of
these things are combining maybe this is
still you know like being studied is
basically lowering the immune system of
the hive as a whole and allowing for
outside pathogens to get in and and and
that you know the pesticides aren't
what's killing the bees it's just sort
of a general lowering of the health of
the bees that then allows for pathogens
to kill the bees this is a problem but
the good news is that it is an economic
problem and and and capitalism is good
at solving those problems because it
says oh god we need to continue selling
our crops and having our bees so we need
like so research is easy to fund
studying colony collapse disorder which
is why there is lots of research being
done on it
the fingers-crossed is that it will get
figured out and we will we will modify
or cease our the use of certain
pesticides and that will allow for bees
to not collapse in their colonies and
that is a thumbs up they the you know
the the feeling that bees in general are
in trouble is not really what's
happening it's more of a humans are in
trouble
situation and we're okay at solving
those because we like being us and we
like selling things to each other I
think one of the things I think about a
lot is the this new word that's emerged
in the last few decades the ant
Anthropocene and throughout the scene I
don't even know how to say it for sure
you know what word I'm referring to
though yeah I think Anthropocene
yeah the Anthropocene the idea that
we're living in this new geological age
were suddenly one species specifically
humans is having an outsize impact on
kind of every facet of life on Earth and
we're still getting used to this power
that we've suddenly had since the
Industrial Revolution to make or break
earth it freaks me out to think about
but we do need to start thinking about
it and I think when we live in denial of
the fact that we're living in this new
geological age when humans can make or
break lots of different things on earth
choosing which species survive choosing
what the carbon levels of the planet are
etc yeah when we kind of put our heads
in the sand and just pretend that we
don't have that power I think it's a
very dangerous indeed indeed
the interesting thing about the
Anthropocene is that it is often stated
as the the age in which humans are the
dominant power but in fact what is more
like is it is an age in which future
geologists would be able to tell a sharp
difference in things like climate and
species diversity in the geological
record and be able to say like this is
marks a new beginning of something new
we are the cause of that new beginning
but the Anthropocene will continue to
exist for hope theoretically a very long
time and that that age may not have
humans as its dominating factor for that
whole time it may just be that humans
were the thing that changed like that
created that defining moment and then
over time it was you know the
Anthropocene continued to exist but
either one humans stopped existing and
the Anthropocene would continue because
future geologists would look at it and
say this age continues and species
diversity did not come back and carbon
levels did not decrease in fact even
without people carbonyls will probably
continue to increase because as things
get warmer carbon dioxide production
increases it's a feedback loop it's bad
and or it could be that we will have
less of an effect but we will continue
to see the those those effects continue
despite the fact that we are having less
of an impact on the earth in the future
through hopefully technology and
intelligence but but the the changes
that we have made will continue they are
they are not something that we can turn
back the clock on yeah this is a great
comedy podcast he's got another question
Hank
this one's from Samantha she writes dear
John and Hank would you rather know what
happens after you die or know everyone's
secrets I would not maybe like to know
either of those things uh well ya know
obviously in a perfect world you
wouldn't know either of those likely
they agree with you a desire to know
what happens after I die and I have no
desire to desire to know everyone's
secrets but I do have a preference and I
think that's what the question is what
is your preference if you are forced to
choose between the two what would you
choose and for me that's easy I would
want to know everyone's secrets I think
that this question is in fact I would
like those are both good things and
phrased it in that way I think some
people would like to know both of those
things but maybe not we are just old
stodgy
muggins and and both of those things
sound awful but to mote too many people
that might sound sound lovely to know
what happens after you die or yeah I
don't I think I yeah I find your
philosophical ramblings interesting but
again Samantha's question is is a value
free would you rather write Tokyo what
happens after you die or know everybody
secrets and to me that's a yes I would
rather know what happens after I die
because knowing everybody's secret
should be no crushing and awful no no no
knowing everyone it would completely
completely remove my ability to be a
human in the world know first off
knowing everyone's secrets would be
incredibly helpful and useful in terms
of navigating the world and you would
quickly become a billionaire and then
you would be able to do something about
malaria so it's a clear win to know
everyone's secrets you just exploit and
abuse other people's secrets to get
billions and billions of dollars which
you then use to fight global poverty
obvious um for instance I could probably
use knowing everyone's secrets just to
bet on you know like to bet on future
sporting events or whatever because I
would know who's secretly injured um
versus knowing what happens after I die
that's going to ruin the rest of my life
because I'm just going to be too focused
on it I'm going to be thinking about it
too much what I want to be thinking
about is what is happening now while I'm
alive that I can do to abuse other
people's secrets to become a billionaire
who then cures cholera ah I yeah I think
that I would be very little affected by
knowing what happens after I die well
but you also think you do know what
happens after you die I do think I know
what happens after you - how you're
right so I think that might be slightly
biasing you here on the question anyway
long story short listeners try to find
out everyone's secrets um what's next
ank we have a question from loyal loyal
says dear Hank and John I'm going to
college soon so I have a lot of choices
to make not only must I decide what to
study but I'm also toying with the
decision to start going by a nickname I
really do like my name but I hate
introducing myself because my name is
also an adjective and people think I'm
describing myself plus I'm socially
awkward and even though loyal is a boy's
name I'm
girl and etc uh beyond that I've started
the question if changing what people
call me will change me as a person so my
question is this how much does a
person's name shape their identity and
do you think I should start going by a
nickname in college I have always gone
by a nickname my name is William Henry
Greene and they call me Hank my parents
called me Hank from the day I was born
which is a fate that I would never
suggest a parent bestow upon their child
because it results in the bank often
saying this check is not for you and me
saying oh please please please give me
my money
but I think that loyals question is very
interesting specifically the first off
can we just pause and note that loyal
has a fantastic name yes and that in my
opinion it's not a boy's name or a
girl's name it's just a great name
correct
top notch name so I mean first shout out
to your parents loyal or whoever named
you because that's that's some good
naming right there I I have a lot of
background in the field of choosing your
own nickname because I tried to do it
throughout middle school I don't know if
you know this about me Hank no yeah so I
chew I I wanted a nickname but nobody
would give me a nickname because like
nobody was even kind of aware of my
existence um so they didn't know me by
my name or by my nickname
so my nicknames only existed in my head
but in sixth grade I tried to get this
nickname going shrimp I really wanted
people to call me the shrimp or just
shrimp ah because you know I was a
smaller person and it was something of a
derogatory nickname but it was at least
a nickname you know like at least then I
would be a nicknamed person instead of
just kind of non-existent person so I
really tried hard to establish this
identity of shrimp I I would I would
always I would ask people to call me
shrimp
I would behave in ways that I thought
were shrimp like by the way I do I do
like shrimp um I think they're fantastic
animals are the animals yes I got our
labels I just love the ideas of watching
middle school John uh like act in
shrimp-like ways whatever that means I'm
bad it's gross I'll tell you Hank as you
can probably imagine it was not a
rich to be shrimp-like I mean I wasn't
trying to act like the animal shrimp I
was trying to act like the slang word
shrimp which was kind of slang for a
person who was maybe weaker and a little
bit less masculine and etc so it wasn't
that much of a stretch for me and then
when I was in high school I again I
desperately wanted a nickname and I
never got one until the last couple
years of high school and I really loved
having a nickname and in some ways I
miss it like I loved being known for
something other than my given name and
I've always been fascinated in my
fiction by the the relationship between
like given identities and chosen
identities like a lot of my characters
have nicknames but also they're you know
generally I'm fascinated by the way that
in in adolescence and the first years of
adulthood were trying to find ourselves
and part of that is like finding a name
for ourselves so in high school I was
called cuffs
kayuu ffs because one time I said that
Christian Slater who was an actor never
made a bad film and it turned out that
he had been in a cop buddy comedy named
cuffs in which his buddy was a was a
police dog in cuffs with a K and I
really enjoyed being called cuffs even
though it was like making fun of this
you know stupid thing that I'd said so
anyway well I think it's totally cool to
have a nickname I got to get school I
think you have a great name as it is but
I also think that if you want to have a
chosen identity as well as your given
identity then that's wonderful we are
the things that we're given we are many
of the things that were born with but we
also get to choose a lot about what we
are so I I think it's I think it's
awesome go for it
Hank give any nickname suggestions for
loyal um no I think that it's a I think
it's difficult to give yourself a
nickname because it's always going to be
awkward to be to like introduce yourself
as something that you're not used to
introducing yourself as and like no I
don't think so I could totally do it
yeah well I mean but you're John Green
and you're very confident in an adult so
there's no no no no like just I could
have done it on my freshman in my
freshman year of college like somebody
walks up to me they ask me what my name
is
instead of saying John I say
I don't know I'm trying struggling to
think of a nickname for myself you got
anything cops I say oh yeah my name is
cuffs cuffs Green good to meet you
actually you're right that would have
been difficult just because cuffs was
such a specific nickname now if it had
been a nickname like I don't know Daisy
pants and people are alive just been
like oh my name's Daisy pants green
people I think people would have
accepted that over time ya know I think
they'll accept it I just think it's odd
it's it would be difficult for me to do
personally at the the thing I want to
say to loyal is that it is actually
really valuable to have a weird name um
like there's something like as a hank
there's something nice about having a
name that's pretty unusual and like
people remember my name which is good
people do not remember like Katherine's
name for example because it's normal her
and and people I think feel like
remember me more and being remembered
is advantageous in general in life so I
think that there's I think there's a lot
good about loyal and in fact it a little
bit sounds like it already is a nickname
and that might be part of what makes it
awkward to introduce yourself as that
people think that you're giving them a
nickname or a you know a you know
something that you've chosen for
yourself and and and you feel weird
about that but I think that that like
comfort in one's identity is one of the
greatest greatest things that we can
achieve as people and it is very
difficult to achieve so whatever you can
do to achieve it is worth attempting so
Hank ultimately what you're suggesting
is that loyal remain loyal to loyal oh
dang the nice thing about when you talk
for like three minutes in a row is that
I get to think of puns ah yes that's
that is really how puns happen you just
have to let a friend monologue for long
enough we've got another question this
one is from Emma Emma says dear Hank and
John there are a lot of accredited
colleges online lots of these places let
you get college credit for taking tests
like AP or C LEP exams I'll be a high
school senior next year I've been
homeschooled since kindergarten so I'm
used to being self-taught if I can get a
college degree using one of these
resources along with things like crash
course
on serve today's episode of dear Hank
and John for test prep
why don't I why should I go to a
brick-and-mortar school is the real-life
experience worth it well I think that
there is a real value to in classroom
education I think that there is a value
to person-to-person physical interaction
and I know that that sounds like a
double entendre and it is this is a
comedy podcast but um Chuck
hey um but I do I think that there's
something valuable about classroom
experiences about IRL classroom
interactions and about IRL experiences
with really really excellent professors
that said it there's also lots of other
things that are valuable about college
that you can get online so I you know
when Hank and I were designing crash
course we we imagined it as a
educational material that didn't try to
replace classrooms as opposed to
everything else that was being done
which which sort of was trying to
replace classrooms because I think we
both really believed in the classroom
experience and and classroom education
and in the power of teachers that said I
think that there are lots of values to
online education and and even if for me
at least it's not as complete an
educational experience it is still very
much a good and valuable educational
experience so that is my way out of
answering your question I also this
probably is just in my mind cuz we were
just talking about identity but I think
that college is a great time to sort of
come to better understand yourself and
and that is most effectively done by
interacting a lot with peers and being
able to have these intense years of of
peer interaction and friend friend
interaction and there are certainly
other ways to find that as well but for
a lot of people you know higher
education is really the time when you
get to hang out with people who are
adults but who are not busy or like
stuck with big other life things like
you know marriage and kids and job
and stuff so it's uh you know those
those relationships are extremely
valuable in my life and I know that they
are in a lot of other people's lives and
not just not just then they were very
valuable then but they continue to be
valuable now so there's good stuff about
college there's good stuff about having
four years or so where you you know you
are really concentrating on personal
growth not just academically but also
you know all the rest of the ways less
it's usually where you meet your college
girlfriend who will later crush your
soul so that's not without value that's
John's experience I got married to mine
well I mean maybe she's just gonna crush
your soul later then all relationships
end Hank either in break-up divorce or
death oh well god I love this comedy
podcast um
why on earth did you make this a comedy
podcast all of our all of our negative
reviews in the iTunes Store are like
perfectly enjoyable but not particularly
funny anyway I don't mean to focus on
the negative but it's also the only
thing that I know how to focus on ha ha
ha ha ha see that was a great joke John
thanks buddy uh so we've got a question
from Josiah he writes dear John and Hank
when 3d printers become widely
accessible what will be the first simple
object you will print and why aah Smurf
maybe something maybe Oh a smart well
you can get Smurfs maybe an action
figure
I think Y print a smurf when you could
like a shirttail shirttails the 1980s
children's television program that
sponsored today's episode of Dear John
and Hank what was I thinking you're
absolutely right now I think I might
sprint a snork
Oh God I had I have such fond memories
of the Snorks in fact when I was
thinking of that shirttails joke I was
trying to think of the Snorks it's funny
because hey Henry watches a show
octonauts
that is today's Snorks like it's he will
remember it the way I remember the
Snorks but I really remembered the
Snorks as the the first and in some ways
most important narrative experience I've
ever had that's really weird that I
think for me that was a show called
Cities of Gold which was not
popular and not on for a long time but I
was really obsessed with it I'd get up
every morning like 7:00 in the morning
on Saturdays to watch it and I had a
huge crush on the cartoon girl well I
think Josiah's question has been
answered but not in the way any of us
expected
no we didn't answer if you want a snark
as well um no I don't think I would
print a snork I think the first simple
object that I would print would probably
be a like a mechanical hand that could
sign my name for me because that's
something I spend a lot of my leisure
time doing that might not be qualifying
as simple what about an Xbox controller
because mine is always breaking is that
simple no I'm just kidding of course I
would I would my first 3d printing
project would be a bobble head version
of Hank I'm no dummy I just want a
bobble head Hank in my life I have a
bobble head you in my life already I'm
looking at him right now he looks a
little weird cuz he you have a bobble
head Hank or a bobble head John yeah
yeah but bobble John over there he looks
a little weird cuz his head fell off
once and now it doesn't quite rest
correctly so your chin sort of like
leans on on your like that your right
shoulder kind of fin it yeah like you
okay there buddy like I had a long night
yeah my other big issue with the bobble
head John's which I think were produced
in 2008 or 2009 is that I'm a little
concerned that that bobble John looks
significantly younger and thinner than
current John and it hurts my feelings
sometimes to look at look at my bobble
head self which I'm doing right now I'm
just like who's that handsome young
large headed human yeah that's a norm
that's that's not used to be that guy
you've gotta you gotta be okay with the
skin that you're in John oh man that's
good that's that's good dubious advice
Hank um we've got another question this
one is from Leah she writes dear John
and Hank recently my grandma died she's
been with me my entire life and I've
always thought of her as a second mother
it's only been a week but I'm doing okay
I don't think I'm as sad as I should be
it was really hard the first few days
and whenever I think about her I feel
sad but generally I'm fine does this
mean that I'm heartless am i a bad
person for not being completely
devastated for longer than a couple days
about the death of someone I loved so
much this has been constantly on my mind
would really appreciate an answer this
sounds like a John Green question to me
Leah you are fine there are lots of ways
to grieve and there are lots of kinds of
grief and judging your grief or other
people's does not do you any good you
are not heartless if you were heartless
you would have been already you would
already know it's it's perfectly
possible that your grandmother lived a
long and full and rich life and that you
feel very grateful to have had the time
with her that you had and that that
you've integrated the sadness that you
feel about her death into your life and
that it's part of your life but not a
consuming part and that's not unhealthy
you're okay I promise
I I wasn't that sad when my grandma died
and I was very close to her as well so
yeah does that make me sound heartless
Hank now I'm concerned now now I'm
feeling exactly what Leah felt nope you
do not sound too heartless and I thought
your answer was very good I think a lot
of times we like to judge our grief or
other people's grief but um yeah your
grief is yours and it's okay it really
is it's also okay if in three months you
find yourself suddenly extremely sad
about that loss like one of the
difficult things that I go through a lot
is like judging my own feelings and
making my life worse by judging them so
I'll be like I'm sad and also I'm angry
at myself for being sad and also I'm
angry at myself for being angry about
being sad and then that I'm pretty far
away from where I should be which is I'm
sad and that happens sometimes
yeah great answer John not as good as
your answer about the B's which was full
of information that I did not know can I
tell you a funny story about bees Hank
you want to tell me a story about bees
if you don't mind do you have a second I
do so my son is in preschool and I got
an email a few weeks back and and in all
capital letters the subject line of the
email was the bee incident and then the
email itself was like the first the
first sentence was I just want to
reassure all
parents that our students and heroic
teachers are all fine and I was like
what the hell has happened and it turns
out that two students and three heroic
teachers were stung by a nest of ground
bees in the playground on the campus of
the school itself but to read this to
read this email you would have thought
that there had been a catastrophe on the
scale of the Lusitania sinking that like
not not since the Titanic itself has
humanity struggled with such a
catastrophe and then the last sentence
of the email was I would again like to
thank all of our heroic teachers yeah
that's uh that's life in the
contemporary American preschool these
days that's just that's just good
management she's making everybody feel
good the B incident this question is
from Bailey Bailey asks dear Hank and
John if given the choice would you
rather know virtually nothing but be
incredibly happy or would you rather
know everything but be incredibly
miserable Oh Bailey we seemed it like
answering these hypothetical questions
Hank I've never taken a ton of value in
hypothetical questions I'm not sure how
our podcast became the hypothetical
question podcast but I'll answer this
question this is a you know it's a bit
of a Faustian dilemma right like there's
the character not just in in goethe's
faust or or dr. Faustus or anything but
also in like The Little Mermaid there's
always a character in a Faustian dilemma
who makes a deal with the devil in
exchange for knowledge and then of
course the deal with the devil comes
comes full circle and you know as a
result of your knowledge you have to
suffer some terrible fate possibly
including Hellfire and you know and then
on the other hand you've got the great
examples of the sort of like happy happy
but ignorant people of I don't know say
John Barnes is novel lost in space you
can take a drug that makes you
increasingly happy as you
get as as you know less and less you
become happier and happier I would uh I
don't know Hank what would you rather do
um I would rather know everything but be
incredibly miserable because then other
people could be happy because of my
knowledge that it everything is a lot of
things and I think you probably would be
incredibly miserable if you knew
everything but if you knew everything
then you could make a lot of people's
lives better
and that would be an okay trade-off yeah
that's a really good point actually cuz
you could probably cure cancer if you
knew everything yeah yep you could yeah
I mean knowing everything would be so
incredibly valuable not just to the
human species but to the universe as a
whole to like the idea of life that you
would almost be a bad person not to take
that choice you know not to make that
sacrifice on the other hand the one
question is if you are incredibly
miserable are you able to help anyone at
all because of your incredible misery or
do you become dr. Manhattan and you're
just like I'm incredibly miserable and I
understand how to make people happier
but why even bother then that's a great
question because if you're so miserable
yep yeah on the other hand I don't think
that being happy is particularly the
point of being alive right yeah I
remember I was I was dating a girl once
I don't know why this is the
ex-girlfriends episode of Dear John and
Hank but I was dating a girl once and
she was talking to me about how I was I
was very unhappy and and and you know I
should be more happy and I realized in
the conversation that I just I don't
value happiness particularly highly I
value productivity and connectiveness
and attentiveness and I certainly value
you know love and loving relationships
and everything but I don't know that I
really seek happiness as such maybe I
should maybe have been underrating
happiness this whole time now I'm having
an existential crisis in the middle of a
comedy podcast that's not unusual here
dear Hank and John I value happiness
fairly highly myself
I think that it is a lot of the point of
life and I think that it guides you in
good ways right what is happiness really
well now I'm starting to think that not
only have I been undervaluing happiness
all of this time but that in the last
like five or so years I've secretly been
valuing happiness more than I thought
which is maybe part of the reason why
I've been doing more work that I enjoy
and generally feeling better about being
alive um now I'm thinking that well been
under appreciating happiness but I've
also I've been secretly appreciating
happiness it's getting too meta Hank
we've got to go to another question I
feel like maybe dear dear Hank and John
has become really good talk therapy
Friedel's becoming good talk therapy for
me could we talk about how it was
bullied in middle school that's the
number one subject of my therapy
sessions um also uh actually Hank wall
Dear John and Hank is becoming a therapy
session for me I want to share with you
this question from Julia that is of
great personal interest to me Dear John
and Hank ever since I was a seven or
eight I've had a couple strange habits I
talked to myself flare my nostrils and
sometimes bulge out my eyes not all at
once without even realizing what I'm
doing I've noticed people being really
creeped out by it and expressing concern
for my mental health because of it as
well I pretend I don't care but I do
it's annoying and it's something I
really hate about myself I will soon
start my junior year of high school
which means I will soon start the
college looking application process and
I don't want to have these really creepy
things sort of hanging over me for the
rest of my life any advice on how to
stop well Julia this is a question that
I I can relate to maybe in a way that
isn't going to be helpful to you but
first I want to say that Dear John and
Hank is a podcast full of dubious advice
and that if you want actual good advice
you should definitely talk to a health
professional in this case and mental
health professional which I would
probably recommend anyway just because
this seems to be something that's really
upsetting to you and really difficult
for you to deal with when I was in high
school and and before that and well
after that I had these uh these these
compulsions I guess I have OCD and one
of them was actually talking to myself
like I needed to talk to myself very
quietly and
that I think ultimately wasn't that
distracting people around me but I did
need to do it sometimes I don't know if
that's what similar to what you're going
through I don't know if these feel like
things that you have to do I don't know
if they're tics or compulsions or just
habits and it's impossible for for me to
know but I guess what I would say is
that you know a I'm sorry that you know
you feel so uncomfortable with these
with these parts of your life and be
it's really really difficult to know
what's going on when you're kind of
stuck inside of your own head and that's
why I think it is really useful to talk
to someone for whom this is an area of
expertise yeah and uh it annoys you that
is the main thing to be concerned about
if you are perceiving the annoyance of
other people you may be perceiving their
feelings incorrectly and oftentimes you
know I have friends who have weird fun
habits and I just think of that as how
they are not as something that that is
you know annoying about them so um all
right so we are about to head into the
news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon but
first we have a correction from a couple
podcasts ago one of our sponsors was the
Orlando solar bears which I referred to
as a defunct International Hockey League
team from the 1990s this was in fact a
true statement because the International
Hockey League team the Orlando solar
bears does no longer exist but and part
of the reason for that is that the
International Hockey League does no
longer exist but there is an American
Hockey League team that started in 2012
called the Orlando solar bears that took
over the legacy of the IHS Orlando solar
bears and they do exist the solar bears
are a current team and they play at the
TD Waterhouse Center or whatever the
arena in Orlando is now called I have
not lived there in a while and you can
go watch them they have a tendency of
roughly 6000 people per game so there
are seats available
the Orlando solar bears are a real thing
they just weren't for about a decade
they really sponsor our podcast or was
that part was that part but no they did
not actually give us any money no one
gives us money did they sponsor our
correction no a person on Twitter told
me this oh that's disappointing thanks
to the Orlando solar bears however for
reacting they are one of the great
sporting memories of my childhood
speaking of great sporting memories
let's talk about the news from AFC
Wimbledon this week Hank I mean as
always it's an incredibly exciting week
for AFC Wimbledon they just drew their
their first-round Capital One Cup tied
the Capital One Cup is a competition in
which all the teams in the Football
League play each other so in the first
round AFC Wimbledon will be playing at
Cardiff City fascinating matchup for
Wimbledon for a couple reasons first off
our manager Neal Ardley used to play for
Cardiff also used to play for Wimbledon
and he began his coaching career there
but also a Cardiff City is a is a great
more recent example of the same process
through which AFC Wimbledon kind of came
to exist so Hank as you know there was a
team that played in Wimbledon for 120
years called Wimbledon FC that was moved
by I try to be as objective as I can
here and not biased but it was moved by
greedy actively evil owners to Milton
Keynes where it became the the filthy
pond-scum currently known as MK Dons and
that left the community of Wimbledon
without a football club so they formed
their own football club which is
entirely owned by its fans and worked
their way up from the ninth tier of
English football all the way back into
the Football League back into being a
full-time professional team so that
there is now again full-time
professional football for that community
to support and this and and this is
evidence to me that like football clubs
are not ultimately you know businesses
owned by people they are ultimately
communities Cardiff City has gone
through some some of this as well
because they were bought by a guy named
Vincent tan who unfortunately for him
looks like a 1970s Bond villain but also
has been acting like a 1970s Bond
villain he changed the Cardiff has
traditionally been known as the
Bluebirds and he changed the uniform
color to red from
and started trying to affiliate them
with dragons instead of with bluebirds
and Cardiff City fans started to boycott
games and they would sing where Cardiff
City will always be blue and they would
only wear their old blue uniforms to two
games and they refused to buy the new
red jerseys and eventually the owner of
Cardiff City capitulated and this will
be the first season opener game in in
several years in which Cardiff City will
be playing in blue so congratulations to
Cardiff and their supporters on getting
to play in blue and getting to be the
club that they have historically been
and saying no to their owner but I hope
that you get crushed by the mighty
machine that is AFC Wimbledon on August
11th that was some really fascinating
news from AFC Wimbledon John I am
riveted to my seat I only wish there I
can't tell if you're doing more but we
have to get on to the Marcie well there
we have it but I have to butter thanks
for mentioning it there is more Callum
Kennedy AFC Wimbledon's left-back has
signed a new contract after a recent
return to form he's you know he had a
difficult second half of the season but
but he's showing a lot of promise he's
still a young player Callum Kennedy he's
going to be an AFC Wimbledon player
again next season I'm sorry was there
news from more but we have to get on to
the bars News thank you for your AFC
Wimbledon news John six scientists who
were taking part in an eight month long
Mars simulation mission have been
released and are now part of human
society again they spent eight months in
a dome together a very small area with
very limited privacy and and every time
they went out of the dome to do science
on the slopes of mount Aloha in Hawaii
they had to wear spacesuits upon
emerging from the dome they said the
things that they missed the most were
their families peaches and the feeling
of wind which they did not experience
for eight months which I can imagine is
somewhat up
setting but they they were eight people
are six people selected for for their
their temperament and their scientific
knowledge to be a good team and to be
able to spend eight months together and
not go nuts and and they succeeded and
we now know that that is possible now
they're going to do it again and at this
time for twelve months I believe where
they will have people and basically
participating in human experiments to
see how people handle living together in
close quarters of being able to shower
for only six minutes a week and and not
not not go nuts and and still be able to
do interesting science that sounds like
my idea of hell
it does sound awful it does sound awful
you know you know colonizing Mars is all
fine and good until I can only shower
for six minutes a week let me ask you a
quick question about that though Hank
how often were they allowed to take nice
comfortable soaking baths hahaha because
I could handle only six minutes of
showering a week but I'm gonna need
eight to ten really chest-deep baths the
very hot water one of the most
fascinating things about this is that
one of the crew members jocelyn done
when she walked out she she was a little
bit afraid to leave the enclosure
without her suit on Wow and after after
doing it for eight months she was like
can can i really go outside and is that
okay Wow
just terrifying yeah I mean Hank I don't
like to enjoy the news from Mars but
that actually was interesting primarily
because it was the news from Earth well
I appreciate your appreciation so that's
all the news from the world's greatest
fourth tier football club and also all
the news from the solar system's fourth
Rock from the Sun which brings us I'm
afraid Hank to the end of our podcast
for the day what did we learn oh gosh I
should probably take notes because I
always forget what we learned well we
learned that the Snorks were the
greatest television show of the 1980s
yes we learned that that
John and I disagree about about the
implications of knowledge about the
afterlife and we learned that Hank is
very knowledgeable about bees I wonder
what Hank isn't knowledgeable about it's
kind of frustrating sometimes well I
stand in front of a camera and am paid
to talk about science so even when I
don't know about things someone has
written a script and then I read the
script and then I do know the thing and
we learned it against all odds the
Orlando solar bears are still a thing
yeah that's six very exciting I suggest
all or Landon's get your butt's to those
games sounds like a good time
all right go solar bears thank you for
listening we'll be back again next week
you can send your questions to dear Hank
and John at gmail.com or visit us online
I'm at John Green on Twitter and Hank is
it Hank green yes thank you to Nick
Jenkins for editing this podcast and as
we say in our hometown don't forget to
be awesome